ladies and gentlemen it is an honor for
us to have on the show the infamous
dictator Benito Mussolini Oh grazie
now Benito Kony Benito well my friends
they call me Benito but none of them are
brown
so no hay oh he was talking oh my
goodness when I need good ratings racism
can be king areas and I ride
very funny ha ha ha now mr. Mussolini I
don't mean to embarrass you but we have
found something very special from your
past take a look
Oh Diego that house is the first place I
politically persecuted someone for being
different than me am i right round of
applause he really tells it like it is
force really tells it like it is mr.
Mussolini let's take a serious note you
have been known to say some pretty
controversial things hmm some would even
say hateful rhetoric ok that's true now
in light of that there's a question I
must ask you that the folks at home
deserve to know is Mussolini a ticklish
man ah ha ha if you ticklish see that
they call you may I tickle you ok ok
you have human eyes and we will be right
back